une américaine à paris la présence dans
notre capital de kim basinger va sans
doute te réchauffer l'atmosphère
la belle kim et avec son mari dans la
vie l'héroïne de guet-apens un remake
comme dirait pas jacques toubon d'un
scénario tournait il ya 20 ans par steve
mcqueen et ali macgraw une sorte de
bonnie and clyde version torride nicolas
cornu langlois a rencontré kim et elle
n'a eu d'yeux que pour son mari alec
baldwin doc et carole travail tendue au
il est expert en cambriolage elle et sa
compagne fidèle leur amour et leur
confiance leur sert de rempart de
protection
monsieur et madame baldwin donne aussi
une impression de complicité pardon
bonne chance et aux césars c'était une
surenchère de séduction en plus ils ont
un sens de l'humour très prononcé et dès
que la caméra tourne
ils redeviennent des super pro il
s'entraîne pour le casse du siècle avec
une parfaite maîtrise elle est une vraie
machine à tuer je suis très physique de
toute façon j'aime vraiment tous les
aspects physiques d'un rôle je fais le
maximum de ce que je peux faire juster
que ma doublure prennent le relais mais
je crois que ce qui est excitant c'est
de le faire ensemble tous ensemble et
c'est génial
et vous avez aussi des scènes très
érotique est ce plus facile quand on
marque etc avec des partenaires
étrangers
c'est plus facile quand on est marié et
le doute un jour ça signe chez ce couple
parfait parce que karol du trailer pour
le sauver et vous attaquez vous jaloux
mais peut-être je préférerais embrasser
redford
peut-être et qui peut le savoir vous
savez l'embrasser
aurélie champagne et le soir chez vous
vous refaites le film puis les yeux
s'ouvrent tout d'un coup je lui dis je
pose une question il savait dans la
journée nous étions les héros doc les
carottes et le soir à la maison on
revenait jours kemelek c'était
merveilleux
ça vous a plu à nous sommes enchantés et
le film est aussi sympathique que vous